[MUSIC PLAYING]
ALEX VOGENTHALER:
Well, hi everyone.
I'm Alex Vogenthaler.
I'm the product management
lead for Google Drive, which
means I have fundamental
responsibility for product
strategy, product roadmap,
design of the product,
working with our engineering
and user experience teams,
to get everything built
out and launched to you.
I am incredibly excited
to be here today.
You got a preview
of some of what
we're going to be talking about
in this session in Prabhakar's
keynote earlier this morning.
This is a very big
day for Google Drive.
This is certainly the
biggest day for Google Drive
since it launched
almost five years ago.
My team has been in
the field with you
and many of your peers--
IT leaders, analysts,
and others--
understanding what your
fundamental enterprise
requirements are for
not just enterprise
file sync and share
systems, but really your
needs for content management and
content discovery in the cloud.
We've invested, no
exaggeration here,
hundreds of engineering
years over the last few years
building out the capabilities
that you need to take advantage
of a system like Drive.
I'm going to walk you
through, with the help of some
of my coworkers,
five major launches
today covering the
gamut of what you
need to see in a solution
like Google Drive.
What those five
launches sum up to,
is that today's
the day where Drive
is really ready for
large enterprises
and we're very excited to be
able to take you through it.
Before we get into
the details, I
want to call out an
elephant in the room, which
is all of us come to
sessions like this
because we are really
excited about the possibility
of new digital technologies to
change the way that we work.
You walk around this
conference and you
hear all about machine learning
and Kubernetes and Cloud
and the kinds of things
that we're doing in G Suite.
The elephant in the room
is that as an IT leader,
you're really confronted
with an unfortunate choice.
On the one hand, you can adopt
revolutionary technologies that
really make amazing improvements
available to your business
and suffer the risks that
come along with those.
Teams come to work the
day after some big tech
rollout and the help desk
phone is ringing off the hook.
People aren't able to get
access to their content
and business grinds
to a halt. You
have to decide whether
you want the revolution
and the improvement
with the attendant risks
or same old, same old.
Predictability, stability,
comfort, and control.
Those are both
important things and you
shouldn't have to choose.
In reality, your business
needs both of these things.
Your competitors are
not standing idly by.
Your competitors are innovating.
They're changing
and you need to make
the same kind of
revolutionary changes
or you risk being left behind.
But on the other hand, if
you're a large enterprise--
tens or even 100,000 employees--
predictability is critical
and you shouldn't have
to choose between these things.
Now, the perception of
Google, and rightly so,
is that Google,
historically, has
been very focused on the
left-hand side of this visual.
And it's for good reason.
Google Search.
Who remembers using AltaVista?
OK, I see a lot of hands.
The first time you used Google
Search, your eyes popped open
and like oh, there's no
comparison between these two
things.
When I got my first
Gmail account,
the email that I had been
using with Hotmail at the time
had two megabytes of storage
and Google rolled out
a gigabyte of storage
with Gmail on day one.
These are the kind of things
that Google is known for.
It's in our DNA.
The perception is this is
where we really focus, perhaps
to the exclusion of the
other side of that visual.
Drive is no exception here.
I'll through a couple of things.
Google Drive, since day one,
has supported a maximum file
size of five terabytes.
That's 1000 times
the maximum file
size of our primary competitor.
We were the first to
launch unlimited quota.
Security has been
built in from day one.
All the content you
upload to Google Drive
gets automatically
scanned for viruses,
and that's been from day one.
I'll give you a really
impressive visual
here of something that
launched last year.
You can now use natural language
English queries to search
for your content in Drive.
So when I want to find
something from my coworker Ron,
I can say spreadsheets
from January with Ron.
And it parses my English
grammar and returns what I need.
One final example and
then I'll move on.
100% of the content you
upload to Google Drive
gets run through our optical
character recognition system.
So it could be a PDF,
of essentially image
files, that are coming in
from your legal department.
They're all getting
scanned and when
you need to go
back and figure out
what your indemnity clauses
were in some contract,
you type in the word
indemnity into Google Drive
and all of those documents
get returned to you,
even though they weren't
actually written in free text.
So Drive, Google--
we've historically
focused on the left-hand
side of that equation.
But we really
understand and have
gone through the cultural
and organizational
pivot to deliver enterprises
the controls and the guardrails
that they need to be able
to access that innovation.
Because we know, as a
responsible IT leader,
you can't just go do the next
hottest thing because buildings
could fall down.
Are you going to be able to meet
your compliance obligations?
Are you putting
your organization
at risk for a data breach?
Are you being the responsible
IT leader you need to be?
So we're changing the story.
The five launches we're
walking through today
really focus on the right-hand
side of that equation,
so that you don't have to
make this either/or choice.
We're letting you get
both of these together.
Google will always invest
on the left-hand side
in the innovation.
We have significantly grown the
size of the Google Drive team
over the course of
the last three years.
Spent hundreds of
hours in the field
and hundreds of
engineering years
developing the
capabilities that you
need around control,
security, compliance,
to deliver that reliable
solution you need.
So there are four fundamental
challenges the launches
we're rolling out today address.
I'm going to walk you through
each of those at a high level--
bring up some of my
coworkers to talk you
through the details
of those capabilities.
We're going to do
a few demos and I
think you'll see that these
launches that roll out today
really make Drive the enterprise
capability that you need.
So challenge number one,
that we need to address,
is all of your employees have
a set of expectations and needs
that have evolved over the
course of, at this point,
almost 30 years, for how they
find and work with content.
And those expectations have been
built up from how they interact
with network file shares and
on-prem content management
systems--
things like SharePoint.
All of the file sync and share
solutions on the market today
are a fundamental mismatch
versus these user expectations.
They were designed, initially,
as a way for individuals
to store their
content in the cloud
and sync it across
multiple devices.
They weren't designed
with a team in mind.
And teams have these different
expectations and patterns
of working.
So we have to design a
storage content management
system that works for
the way that teams work.
So that's point number one.
Think about the end
users in your enterprise.
Now, if we can take care of the
end users in your enterprise,
as an IT admin you start
to think OK, maybe this
is something my people
would want to use,
but is it going to work for me?
Is this going to allow me
to fulfill the compliance
obligations that I have to
protect against data breaches--
to control how our confidential
information gets shared, when
and with whom, and for how long.
So we need to take care of your
needs and we're doing that.
If we can address that problem,
you start to get excited.
OK, my users and
my organization are
going to get what they need.
I'm going to get the
control that I need.
It would be great if we
were on this solution,
but the prospect of migrating
from the existing on-prem
storage that you have into
this new solution in the cloud
can just seem daunting.
To quote one of my coworkers,
his favorite expression
is let's think about whether
the juice is worth the squeeze.
And in this case,
unless we help you
with migration
capabilities, the juice
might not be worth the
squeeze-- could just
be too high of a barrier
and too disruptive.
Imagine people
come in on day one
and the content's all
in a different place
or the permissions
aren't mapped properly.
Or it could just be that there
were so many years and decades
of content built up in
these preexisting systems,
that when people come into
the new system all of a sudden
they feel like they're under
a deluge of old, irrelevant
content and they can't find
what they're looking for.
So we're investing in
migration capabilities
that solve this problem.
Point four.
If we can take care
of your end users--
if we can take care
of you and IT--
and then we can
help you migrate--
your next worry--
you're not done yet--
your next worry is OK I
put all my data there,
what's going to break?
All these tools,
all these business
processes that we've
architected that
assume the content's in
this particular place
and it's accessed
in a certain way--
are those going to stop working?
Is my finance team going
to be able to execute
their end of quarter
close process using
all those interlinked
Excel spreadsheets?
Is that going to work?
So we have a launch rolling
out today that specifically
addresses the backwards
compatibility needs that you
have that make Drive work with
all of those existing business
processes and tools.
The result is Drive's stronger.
Drive's enterprise-grade.
You don't have to make
this either/or choice.
You can have it both ways.
So point number one, legacy
fileshares and content
management expectations.
This is a very simple model from
our user experience research
team of how users think about
what content goes where.
Most users are still
in a mode of thinking,
my stuff goes on my hard
drive, my team's stuff goes
on the server, whether that
server's a network-mapped
fileshare--
whether that server is a
content management system.
Unfortunately, this isn't how
existing cloud storage systems
are architected.
So get ready to raise your hand.
How many of you,
in the last week,
have instant messaged one of
your coworkers and said hey,
I can't find whatever,
can you send me the link?
Right, a lot of hands go up.
That's a representation
of the fact
that existing tools
aren't working.
Teams have a really hard
time finding their content,
discovering it,
getting back to it,
organizing it, understanding
who has access.
So today we're announcing
the general availability
of a new capability
called Team Drives.
Of everything I've
done in my career,
this is one of the two largest
projects I've ever worked on.
It is essentially a fundamental
rewrite of all of Google Drive,
from just under the
user interface layer
all the way down to
the storage system,
including the API,
all of the clients,
everything else in between.
It changes the sharing model.
It changes the
ownership model to make
it appropriate for teams.
My coworker, Diane Chaleff,
is going to come up on stage,
walk you through a
bunch of this in detail,
and then give you a great demo.
DIANE CHALEFF: OK, so I
know most you don't know me,
but I really like to cheer.
It's not a joke, so we're
going to all get excited.
Team Drives, woohoo!
Team Drive, yeah!
Awesome.
So we're going to stay on the
slides for a quick minute.
So bear with me.
I'm going to run through
a few slides quickly
to talk about what
Team Drives is,
how it can be helpful
for your organization,
and then we'll jump
into some demo.
So first up, the biggest change
in Team Drives that we bring
is that we make Drive
transparent, predictable,
and understandable
for large teams.
And we do this primarily by
introducing a new sharing model
that has one very basic rule.
Everyone on the Team Drive
sees everything inside.
Your users will no longer
question, oh well when
I added John to the
Team Drive, did he
only see half the files
or some of the files?
No, it's super straightforward.
Everyone sees everything inside.
Likewise, when I put a
file into the Team Drive,
I know exactly who has access.
So users don't under-share
or over-share their content.
So next up here
is that we ensure
that new team
members automatically
get content right away.
And when we do this,
it's because when
you're added to a Team Drive,
that Team Drive automatically
appears in your navigation.
So how is a user
added to Team Drive?
Well one of two ways.
Team Drives are composed of
individuals, like you and me,
and/or groups, like
marketing at my domain.
So you can think about this
as the to line on an email
address.
So once someone's
added to a Team Drive,
we automatically
put that Team Drive
in their left-hand navigation.
And this is really helpful when
it's an employee's first day
of work.
Often, you're provisioning
them to many systems,
perhaps using Google Group
or Active Directory to do so,
and now that content will
seamlessly flow through.
And they'll open Drive and
see all their team's work.
So, most importantly, files
they put in the Team Drive--
I never want to have to wonder
like oh, it's on someone else's
local hard drive.
And now they're on vacation
and I can't get access
or they've left the
team and moved on.
All files on the Team Drive
always belong to the Team Drive
and will permanently be there
even as team members change
over time.
And lastly here, permissions are
easy to understand and manage.
So we have four
different user roles
that you can have for your
users on the Team Drive.
And I'm going to take a quick
second to talk about one
of those roles,
which is edit access.
And we think this role
is really special,
because it's
essentially the role you
can give your users so they
can collaborate, but not break
anything.
So users with edit access
can add new content,
can edit existing
content, which I
like to refer to as happy
collaborative actions,
but they can't delete
content or move content out
of the Team Drive.
And so this means if
you have a user who
is a little hesitant to
adopt new technology,
you can say to them, guess what,
you literally can't do anything
wrong besides upload like,
thousands of photos of puppies,
which who does not want
to see photos of puppies?
That usually goes
over a lot better,
like, puppies are really fun.
Puppies are really fun.
OK, so I know I talked
a lot about the user.
I want to talk for a
minute about the admin.
We think it's really
important in Drive,
to both be giving
users capabilities
to do the actions
that they need,
as well as giving
admins the capability
to understand what's
going on with the content
in their organization.
So we have a whole
array of admin features.
I'm only going to touch on
a couple of them quickly.
So one is admins can see
a list of all the Team
Drives on their domain and they
can manage those Team Drives.
And that management
comes in a few flavors.
So first off, users are
creating Team Drives
and editing membership.
And admins can also be
editing membership for a Team
Drive behind the scenes.
So admins can be adding users,
removing users, and changing
those users' roles.
Also, with Team
Drives, all your events
show up the Drive
Audit log, just
like files do today
and actions today that
take place in my Drive.
In addition to
these capabilities,
we have the capabilities
to restore deleted content.
So if you have a user that
deletes content and wants
to get it back,
you, as an admin,
can go in and recover
also other Team Drives
and also find Team Drives
with specific sets of members.
So we know that Team Drives
is a really big step forward
in how Drive might be
used in your organization.
And so we want to aid in
that deployment process.
And we do that in four ways.
So, first off, Team Drive,
it's in your control
how you deploy it.
You can pick which users in your
company can create Team Drives.
And generally the
way we see this used
is that IT admins or team leads
will go in and make a few Team
Drives for their team
to get them started--
maybe have a lunch and learn--
get everyone familiar
with Team Drives
and then turn on creation for
the department or the team.
So we're really
excited that you have
a lot of control over
that deployment process
and encourage you to
roll out Team Drives
as it makes sense for
your organization.
Next up, we also offer a
change management guide, again,
to help with some of
these best practices.
In-product training
that walks your users
through the new feature and,
as always, our Help Center.
So, with that, I'm going
to jump over to the demo.
And I'm about to get a lot
taller, so I'm really excited.
You guys ready?
OK, so I know on the stage
that I was working at Google,
but now I work for
a toy manufacturer.
So just picture I changed jobs.
And I'm going to
walk you through what
my life is like as a
toy manufacturer using
Drive and Team Drives.
So when I first
joined my company
I got told that I was going to
be on the remote control cars
team.
And I immediately was
like, ugh, how am I
going to get up to speed
on everything that we've
been doing with making
remote control cars?
Well, luckily, my team had
already been using Team Drives.
So on day one of work, I went
in, I saw all of my Team Drives
there, and all the files that
belong to the remote control
cars team.
So, pretty straight forward.
I actually did a really good job
working on the remote control
car team.
I'm pretty excited about that.
So my boss came by
and said, you know
what, we're going to put you
in charge of the new Wi-Fi toys
team.
It's toys and it's
Wi-Fi coming together.
So this is very exciting.
You guys excited?
Wi-Fi toys.
Yeah, maybe?
We tried.
We didn't know if that
was going to go over well.
So I got the team together
and we started brainstorming
and had a few ideas.
And I have all these
files here, but I
want to make sure that
they're available to my team.
And so I'm going to go
ahead and make a Team Drive.
We'll jump back in.
I'm going to make a new Team
Drive called Wi-Fi toys.
And, provided the
internet's working--
great.
So I now have the
Wi-Fi toys Team Drive.
But right now this Team
Drive doesn't look so good.
There is no members
on it, besides me,
and there's no files inside.
So let's go take care
of those two problems.
So the first thing
I'm going to do
is I'm going to go
back to my Drive,
I'm going to grab the files
that are relevant here,
and I'm going to move
them into my Team Drive.
And if you watch in
the lower left corner,
it's going to tell me
that all the files moved
and that everyone
who is an existing
collaborator on this Team
Drive now has access.
But as we know, there's
no other people right now
on my Team Drive.
So let's go add some members.
I'm going to add
two people here.
I'm going to add a
group, Wi-Fi toys.
And I'm going to add
my summer intern, Clay.
And I'll leave them
a quick message.
And send.
And now they have access.
And we can see that I've
updated from one member to three
members instantly.
So Clay is a summer
intern and this
is his first job he's ever had.
He's really excited to be on
the team, but as his manager,
I'm a little nervous.
I want to let him
contribute to the space,
but I don't necessarily want
him deleting stuff or adding
other people in the company.
So I'm going to go and
change Clay's role.
And so all of the
options for Team Drives
are under the main menu.
I'll go to manage members, here.
I'm going to take Clay and
I'm going to move him down
to edit access.
Again, that role, so he can
be an effective collaborator,
but not hurt our space.
Now, the last thing
that's come up
is Arie, who's my
colleague in finance.
He is really all
about the numbers
and how much money
we're spending.
He doesn't care at all
about the toys we're making,
which is a little
upsetting, but I get it.
He just wants to know
about the budget.
And so he doesn't want to
be added to this Team Drive.
He wants the one
file that he needs.
So I'm going to
take our budget file
and I'm going to
share it with Arie.
So Arie's been added.
So now Arie will have access
to this one very important file
in our Team Drive.
And if I go back
and I look, we can
see that it's our three
members of our team
with their respective
roles plus Arie.
So that's my quick demo
today for Team Drives.
And now I'm going to hand
it back over to Alex.
ALEX VOGENTHALER: Thank you.
OK, so as I
mentioned, Team Drives
has been an early
adopter program.
We announced that
back in August.
And I'll let everyone read
this quote for a second--
I'm not going to read
it out loud to you--
from Troy at Whirlpool
about how this
is helping their organization.
This is the sentiment
that we get from everyone
who's tried this feature out.
It's been testing with hundreds
of thousands of customers.
At this point we've put over--
I was estimating
it this morning--
over 1,000 hours from our
user experience research team
into this.
And, as you can see, when
Diane walked through that demo,
Team Drives strikes a
really great balance.
We really think we found the
sweet spot between the controls
and the capabilities
and the sophistication
that people need while also
being a very easy to use
product.
So there's some more
information on the last slide
of the presentation
about how you can enable
Team Drives for your domain.
I'll underscore the
point that Diane
made, that you're in control.
You can choose to
turn on Team Drives
today for your entire domain.
Let 1,000 flowers bloom.
Let people there start
creating Team Drives
or you can take a
cautious approach.
Plan out what you want the
information, organization,
of your domain to be.
And only then roll it out
to everyone in your domain.
So if you remember those four
boxes we had on the screen,
we've dealt with the first.
Users who work in
teams have expectations
about what team ownership means
versus individual ownership.
Where my stuff goes.
Where my team stuff goes.
And that's what Team
Drives addresses.
What we have to do now,
though, is make you, the admin,
confident in moving your data
from your on-prem, legacy
system into Drive.
And you, by rights,
should be concerned.
You should be nervous.
You should have us
prove to you that Drive
is going to be an environment
that will keep your data safe,
reduce the likelihood
of a data breach,
and allow you to fulfill
your compliance obligations.
Before I get into
the major launch
that we're rolling
out today, I just want
to highlight this is not a
one and done effort for us.
We actually now have multiple
dedicated teams focused
on building admin controls.
And there's a steady drumbeat
of launches in this area.
We had a major
launch in this area
just as recently as January.
Here we are, two months
later, with the next one.
So I'll get into
that in a second.
But, a recap of what
we launched in January.
So, data breaches.
You should prevent data
breaches in the first place,
rather than having great
tools to remediate them.
You should have
both, but prevention
is where you want to start.
So Drive Data Loss
Prevention allows
you to identify critical
content that shouldn't be shared
outside of your organization.
The classic examples here
are the human resources team
that has files full of
employees' social security
numbers or maybe an accounts
receivable team or order
management team that
has credit card numbers.
You need to ensure that those
numbers, those key identifiers,
don't inadvertently or
purposefully get shared
outside of your organization.
And it's not enough
to just get reporting
after the fact about when that
happens because then the cat's
already out of the bag.
You need to be able
to scan, identify,
and proactively prevent
that content from leaking.
And that's what Drive
Data Loss Prevention does.
It supports a myriad of
special numbers and patterns
across the world.
This is just a subset--
what we could get on the slide.
Social Security numbers
in the United States.
SWIFT banking account numbers.
The list goes on and on.
But you're not just limited to a
predetermined set of templates.
This is fully customizable.
Whatever industry you're in,
whatever geography you're in,
you can come in and
create the rules that
will prevent that
content from leaking
outside of your organization.
You can customize it.
One of the issues
that many solutions
on the market like
this suffer from
is the boy who cried
wolf syndrome, where
they're constantly alerting
and you just end up getting
used to ignoring the alert.
So there was one
little thing over here,
there was one little
thing over here,
and then you don't miss
there were 10,000 hits.
And that slips
past because you've
trained yourself to not pay
attention to these warnings.
There are content count
and frequency thresholds
in Data Loss Prevention so that
you can go deal with an issue
when it rises to
a certain level.
If you remember that slide I had
in the beginning about Drive's
innovations, one of those
fundamental innovations
is optical character recognition
for every piece of content
that gets uploaded
to Drive, including
all the scanned documents
that might come in from legal
or an orders team.
We OCR all that
content, so that content
is also protected by DLP.
So that was in January.
That's available to everyone
on the G Suite Enterprise SKU.
The launch today is in the
area of content governance.
I've talked a lot about
compliance so far.
If you're a large
company, you have
a lot of compliance burdens.
You are probably subject
to some rules that
say data from the
finance team all
has to be retained for a
minimum of seven years.
And you, as the IT
admin, in conjunction
with your legal
team, want to ensure
that 100% of that
content gets deleted
at seven years and a day.
You need tools to
be able to do that.
Another use case is if
you're a big company,
you probably get sued
pretty regularly.
In a lawsuit, you
need to make sure
that no documents are destroyed.
So you have to be able to
put people on a legal hold.
And not just extract the
content that they have,
but guarantee that any
matching content can't
get deleted from the system.
This is what Vault
for Drive does.
It's in general
availability today.
It lets you set these
retention and deletion
controls for all the content
that you have stored in Drive.
It's very easy to set up.
You can set up rules based on
what organization someone works
in, for example, finance.
You can set up rules so
anything related to Project X--
maybe there's a lawsuit
related to Project X--
it's all going to get retained.
And a really important point--
when we say that's deleted,
it's really deleted.
We are subject to a number
of compliance certifications
that require us to be
audited in such a way
that we can guarantee
contractually that when
your data is deleted,
whether by you, your users,
or automatically by
the Vault system,
it's really off our servers.
You don't have to worry
that that data is going
to somehow come back to
life somewhere, which
has been an issue with
some solutions in the past.
So that's Vault.
If you think about
DLP and Vault,
those are just two examples.
Vault's launching today.
There are many
things we've launched
and many more that
are coming up.
Expiring sharing is
one recent launch.
We're really investing
in this whole area
of controls for admin.
So you, as the admin,
can now get comfortable
that if you move your
content into Drive,
you're taking care
of your obligations.
So you could imagine,
hey, this is a solution
I might want to get on to.
But the idea of migrating
on to one of these solutions
can be pretty daunting.
Not only do you actually have
to move file contents themselves
and extract them out of a legacy
content management system,
you also have to map all
of the permissions properly
to make sure no one
loses access to content
and also so that content
doesn't get opened up
too broadly, inadvertently.
You also need to deal with
the issue of legacy data.
You don't want users
in this new system
to feel like they're
drowning under data
that's accumulated over years
in your preexisting system.
So migration is something
we need to help you with.
And so we're very
pleased to announce
our acquisition of AppBridge.
AppBridge is the number one
Google partner for migration
onto the G Suite.
They have an enterprise-grade
solution, a background
in migration from
companies like Metalogix,
and the product they've built
is really quite impressive.
So I'm pleased to bring Cameron
Wallin up onto the stage.
He's going to talk to you
about what he and his team
have built.
CAMERON WALLIN: Thank you very
much for the introduction,
Alex.
And I can't tell
you how delighted
I am to be standing up here
to talk about migration.
It is something
that I personally
am very, very passionate about.
And I'm very much
looking forward
to introducing you to AppBridge.
I've had the pleasure of
working with some of you
in the room today, but for
the benefit of those of you
that I have not had
the pleasure of working
with, I'm going to dive a
little bit through the company,
AppBridge, and then
why, as a company,
we are a fit for Google
and the future of Drive.
So the AppBridge
mission is to provide
enterprise-tested solutions
to transform and migrate
to Google G Suite.
And we are a software company.
Our team really reflects this.
Matthew McKinnon, my
co-founder, and myself
both have computer science
degrees and backgrounds.
And if you look at our
company as a whole,
it's comprised almost entirely
of software developers.
Above and beyond this, previous
to AppBridge, many of us
also have experience in
enterprise content migration
in a different sphere,
particularly SharePoint
migration.
So it is something
that many of us
have really focused
our careers on--
making this
challenge more simple
and making the
process more smooth.
So it's something that we
care about very, very much.
After this presentation,
please feel
free to corner me if
you have questions
or you want to talk migration.
I am very eager to do so.
So, why Google?
Why are we a fit for Google?
Well, there's four main reasons.
And I do understand that
there's only three on the slide.
We'll come to the
fourth in a minute.
But the first is,
from the ground up,
the AppBridge technology has
been architected and designed
for the enterprise.
The second, is the AppBridge
solution scales automatically
on Google Cloud Platform.
And the third, is
that we meet you
where you are today to connect
to your source environment,
to scan and discover
what you have,
and to really make the
transition to the Cloud
more smooth for you.
So from the very
beginning, we knew
we wanted to migrate
people to Google.
And from the very
beginning, we knew
that we wanted to
be able to scale
from migrating a small number
of documents to billions.
This has allowed us to build
an architecture that today
can take advantage of
the unique strengths
and capabilities
of the Google Cloud
infrastructure and the APIs
that it provides, and can really
provide you a solution that
scales from one user migration
to hundreds of thousands.
I want to take a moment to
talk about the fourth reason
that we feel like we're a
very good fit for Google.
And that is customer success.
Migration, if any
of you in the room
have done it before you can
probably attest to this,
can be a challenging
and critical endeavor.
And so, from the
very beginning, it
was really important to
us, as an organization,
to make sure that
customer success infused
everything we did.
Today, that has led to our
global enterprise support
team and a network of experts,
system integration partners,
who really not only understand
how to use this solution,
but also how to get the
most benefit out of it
for their customers.
So let's talk about a
specific customer success that
happened recently in Japan.
Mitsui Home Group is a housing
industry leader not only in
Japan, but internationally.
They partnered
with SoftBank, one
of the largest global
Google Cloud resellers,
who I understand just won a
fantastic award at the Partner
Awards the other night.
Congratulations, if
you're in the room--
to migrate a 20 terabyte
enterprise fileshare,
comprised of over 17
million files and folders.
Through the expertise of
SoftBank running the solution,
not only was this project
completed on time,
but with zero support
tickets on day one.
If you've done a
migration before,
that's an exciting thing to see.
I'm very excited to say
that with the enterprise
focus of Google Cloud, this
will only evolve and enhance
our ability to support
migrations far beyond anything
that we've been
able to do before.
So how can the technology scale
to do something like this?
How could it achieve a
project result like that?
What you're seeing
on the screen here,
right now, is a very
high-level X-ray
of a single transformation
server in an AppBridge
topology.
This might be one of many.
You might have hundreds.
If you're on GCP, you
might have thousands.
And really what this
diagram portrays
is that even at the lowest
scale, a single server,
the technology is designed
to automatically parallelize
the work that needs to
be done on that server.
So traditional problems
you may have encountered--
multi-threading,
centralizing your logging,
optimizing your
Google API calls--
those are all problems
that this architecture
is designed to solve for you.
So let's go a little
higher in the process
and talk a little bit about
migration configuration
and how the experience of
using this solution is.
What you see on the
screen in front of you
is a snapshot of
the Bridges page.
So a Bridge is the term
that we at AppBridge
use to refer to a
migration template.
And so if you are
configuring a migration,
you want to say come from
SharePoint to G Suite.
You set up your mappings.
You set up how your
permissions transform
during that migration.
You set up the
filters on what data
you'd like to leave
behind because it hasn't
been accessed in 10 years.
That's all done and configured
right here, in this Bridge.
But one of the really cool
things about this architecture
is when you run that
Bridge, under the hood,
it will take your
migration corpus
and it will split it up into
what we call Partitions.
And it will do
this intelligently,
as you can see on the
right-hand side there.
These Partitions
will automatically
be load-balanced across your
distributed topology, which
means they get run
on multiple servers.
The more you have, great,
the more you can run.
And in Google Cloud
Platform, this
allows unprecedented
scalability for migrations.
The goal and result
of this technology
is it will create an
optimization based off
of your source corpus,
your actual data, that
is very intelligent
and by doing so,
it helps to remove the
onus on your migration team
from configuring it that way.
So, as I said before, we do
meet you where you are today.
If you are in the
Cloud already--
using a technology like Office
365 or Dropbox or Box, Ignite,
et cetera--
or if you're on
premises and maybe even
using an older version of
one of these technologies--
MOSS 2007.
If you know the acronym,
you're probably using it--
Exchange 2007, older
versions of SharePoint,
older versions of Exchange--
our goal is really to
support you in your drive
to the Google Cloud.
Even G Suite domains can be
used as a source for migration,
which as it is on topic
for this presentation,
I'm very pleased to announce
that direct migration to Google
Team Drives is supported.
So let's talk about
transformation.
It is very rare that,
in our experience,
that a migration is
simply picking up
your data that lives here
and putting it there.
Generally, there are specific
transformation points
in your migration
project that you'll
want to ensure the
software is aware of
and can handle
automatically for you.
To help facilitate this,
I have a few features here
that I'm going to talk
through that really
help you plan your migration and
make sure that it's successful.
The first is the software
includes an entirely fleshed
out discovery, scanning, and
reporting functionality that
allows you to discover what your
corpus looks like before you
actually run your migration.
This is things like
how many objects
do I have, not just
files and folders,
but how many permissions?
How many API calls am I
going to have to make?
If you've done a
migration, you know
that's probably the bottleneck.
Finding out that gives
a really good way
of finding out how long
your migrations will
take in the end.
Things like watch points--
how deep are my folders?
Do I have too many
permissions in places
where they shouldn't be?
This, then, leads
into the ability
to start your migrations
as soon as possible.
Incremental functionality
built into the solution
gives you the ability to run
your migrations initially
and then pick up anything
that's changed in later waves.
So good examples
of this are, say
I want to migrate all
my documents initially
to get the data
there for testing,
for getting the
migration out of the way,
but then I want to migrate
my permissions later.
Incremental migration.
Check a box, rerun it.
No problem.
Another very common
case is if you
migrate a billion documents,
even with [? 6:9 ?] success,
you're going to have
a couple of failures.
So repairing errors during
migration is built in.
You can pick up only the
failures and migrate those.
You don't have to
re-crawl the source, only
re-migrate the failures, and now
if you fix them, they're good.
They're solved.
And as somebody who has run
many migrations in my career,
the last point is really, really
important to me, personally.
Validation.
To make sure that
our customers are
able to be very confident in
the results of their migration,
we've built a data-centric
approach to our logs.
What I mean by that is
every single object--
and I don't mean
document, I mean object--
in the migration is tracked
in your transaction log.
What that means is every
permission, every file,
every folder, it's in there.
You still get the summary
logs, the high-level throughput
statistics, your
error categories,
to fix, broadly, what
might have gone wrong
if you have millions of
documents that have migrated.
But you also get the ability,
if a user files a support ticket
post go live, to filter down
and find the specific document
and what happened to it.
Not only that, it's actionable.
So you can then fix the problem,
rerun that one document--
if you're a helpdesk employee
or someone else looking to solve
this problem for the customer--
right from the log.
So I'm incredibly excited
about the future of migration
with the new partnership between
Google Cloud and AppBridge.
I want to close
with a quote that
was said to me by one
of our larger customers,
a company called LafargeHolcim,
upon the completion
of a 55,000 user, roughly
60-million-object migration
that ran in about six days.
The quote goes as follows,
"When we started this migration
project, the Drive migration
aspect was our biggest concern.
It is now our smallest."
I hope that, through
this partnership,
that mentality, seeing that
experience, becomes the norm.
Thank you very much.
ALEX VOGENTHALER: So you
can see why we wanted them
as part of Google and part of
the Google Drive team, right?
This is the kind of expertise
that we need in-house
to be able to take care of
the challenges that you have.
So a meta-comment here--
Today we're announcing the
acquisition of AppBridge,
but as we are focused on
delivering the capabilities
that IT leaders need,
we are aggressively
partnering, integrating,
and even acquiring,
where required, because we
know that we have to provide
the complete solution to you.
So if you remember
those four boxes
that I had at the
beginning-- number one,
take care of the users.
Number two, take
care of the admin.
Number three, help
with the migration.
Get you over the hump.
Number four is what happens
the day after migration?
All the contents moved.
We've dealt with the errors.
You've validated the audit logs.
And now, if you're
Mitsui Home, you
have tens of
terabytes of content
that used to be
within your walls,
that your users had access
to on the network fileshare,
and now it's in the Cloud.
This laptop here probably has a
128 gig, SSD hard drive in it.
And many of your employees are
running on similar hardware.
And you've now just put
10 terabytes of data
into the cloud.
So how do you get your users
access to all that data
without breaking all of their
training, their expectations,
and the workflows?
I mentioned the example
of a finance team
that's trying to execute
an end-of-quarter close
process with a bunch of
interlinked Excel spreadsheets.
If a couple of those
Excel spreadsheets
have been synced down to a PC
and then it ran out of space--
something was left behind,
a data set was left behind.
Those business processes break.
So we have to help
you with that issue.
And we are, today, announcing
the early access program
for Drive File Stream, which
solves these exact problems.
My coworker, Aakash, is going
to come up, tell you about it,
and give you a live demo.
AAKASH: All right.
Thanks, Alex.
Hi, everybody.
So, I'm Aakash.
And I am just so
excited to introduce
you to Drive File Stream today.
Drive File Stream is a
brand new application,
built from scratch, for
accessing your Google Drive
files on a Mac or a PC.
It works seamlessly
with all of the tools
that your users use today.
And all of your existing
workflows and business
processes can remain intact.
So the magic all
starts by mounting
Google Drive as a network file
system on the user's computer.
So you can see here, we've
got the G drive mounted next
to the C drive, right
where a user would
expect to see their team files
if they were using a fileshare.
And now because
drive file stream
behaves like a
network file system,
the files aren't actually
stored on the user's disk.
Instead, they're
streamed on-demand when
the user goes to access them.
And that's because we've heard
from customers again and again
that when they use
traditional sync clients,
users will sign in and then
immediately their hard disks
will explode because they fill
up their hard disks with all
the content that they
need from Google Drive.
And so Drive File Stream makes
this a problem of the past.
Users can access loads
and loads of files
that occupy only a very small
footprint on their computer.
In addition, we
wanted to make sure
that Drive File Stream was
really easy to understand
for end users.
And for users, there's
actually nothing new to learn.
Drive File Stream
works seamlessly
with all of the applications
they're used to.
They can double click
on a Word document
and it opens in Microsoft Word.
Double click on a PSD and
it opens in Photoshop.
Now, since the files are
being streamed on-demand, you
might be wondering,
hey, what do we
do if we have some
teams that need access
to their files offline?
So, for example, if they
frequently go on customer
visits where the Wi-Fi is
shaky or they fly all the time
and they are on planes
and don't have Wi-Fi--
so we've made that really easy
in Drive File Stream as well.
So with Drive File
Stream users can
right-click on
any file or folder
and choose make
available offline
and then the files get
downloaded and kept in sync,
so that the user can access
them on their computer
no matter where they
are, whenever they like.
Next-- and this one is
really important to me--
Drive File Stream is fast.
The team has worked really,
really hard to make sure
that every action
that a user takes
is super quick, whether it's
navigating through folders,
opening files--
just for a quick example,
the average first sync
takes only about 23 seconds.
So think about it, you
download Drive File Stream,
you install it, you
sign in, and then
within seconds, you
can be up and running
and ready to get productive.
When you compare this to
traditional sync tools,
those can take sometimes
hours or even days
before all of the content is
downloaded to the computer.
So the difference
with Drive File Stream
is because we're not making the
user wait for every single file
to get downloaded,
they can get up
and running almost right away.
And lastly, Drive File Stream
works great for end users.
So, that's good.
But as an extra benefit,
IT professionals
can rest easy knowing that
for the majority of files,
the actual content
of the files is not
sitting on the user's laptop.
So if a device were to get
lost or stolen, all of the data
doesn't necessarily go with it.
So IT teams can be
comfortable knowing
that their important corporate
data is actually safe.
So that's enough talking
about Drive File Stream.
I want to show you
a quick demo of what
it looks like in action.
So we'll switch over to
the demo machine here.
All right, so for
today's demo, we're
going to pretend that I work
with Diane at the toy company
from earlier.
And I actually work
on the marketing team
and I'm preparing for our
big launch later this year.
And I'm planning
for a TV commercial,
so I want to take a look
at some of the files
that they prepared.
And I'm using a Windows
10 computer here,
so I'm just going to
launch Drive File Stream
and I'm going to get signed in.
All right, so I am signed
in and Drive File Stream
is loading my files.
And pretty quickly you see that
my Drive folder has already
opened up, showing me my
Drive and Team Drives.
And if you look
to the side here,
Google Drive is actually
mounted on my computer.
Right here, next to the C
drive, I have a G drive.
Now let's start exploring.
It's pretty cool.
So we're going to
start exploring.
I'm going to pop
into my Drive, here.
And you can see that
right away all my files
are accessible to me.
And I actually have access
to loads of content in here.
This account actually has
access to terabytes of content
and it's taking up almost no
space on this 128 gig laptop.
In this folder,
just to prove it,
I have a bunch of renders
from the previous commercials
that we've aired.
And if you look at the
column on the right
there, with the file
sizes, some of these files
are like 10, 7, 4 gigabytes.
There's no way that all
of these would actually
fit on the computer.
So, of course, with
Drive File Stream,
I have access to all of my
Team Drive content as well.
And I'm going to go ahead and
double-click into Team Drives
and I see, here, the
Wi-Fi toys Team Drive
that Diane created earlier.
So I can hop in
here and I can see
that Diane has shared some toy
designs as well as the launch
plans.
And I can see from
the little cloud icons
that these files are actually
all stored in the Cloud
still, which makes sense
because Drive File Stream didn't
actually download every
single file in advance.
But as an end user, I'd like
to open this launch plan,
but as an end user, I don't
have to learn anything new.
I can just go ahead
and double-click on it
and it opens up in Word,
just like I'd expect.
So I'm going to
go ahead and make
some changes to this
document, hit the Save button,
and close it.
And that's it.
So I didn't have to
learn anything new.
And the latest version
of this Word document
is going to get uploaded
back to our Team Drive
and Diane will see it next time
that she enters the Team Drive.
And this entire
folder, actually,
works just like any
other network mount.
So I can even grab files from
my desktop and just drag them in
and they'll be uploaded
to our Team Drive.
All right.
So there's one last thing
that I wanted to show you.
I'm about to head out to meet
with our marketing agency
to discuss this new commercial.
I'm not sure if I'm going to
have Wi-Fi when I get there.
So I can actually just right
click on this Team Drive
and choose available offline.
And now this Team Drive is
going to be accessible to me,
whether or not I have an
internet connection when
I get there.
And that's Drive File Stream.
So we've piloted Drive File
Stream with a few customers
and we've been just
thrilled with the feedback.
It's been really positive.
And, like Alex mentioned, we're
excited to announce the Early
Adopter Program for Drive
File Stream for customers
on the G Suite Business,
Enterprise, and Education SKUs
starting today.
So we're really excited for you
guys to get your hands on it.
Thank you so much.
ALEX VOGENTHALER: All right.
Let's flip back
over to the slides.
So that Early Adopter Program is
open to everyone on the G Suite
Business and Enterprise SKUs.
So this is not an invite
only, velvet rope party
for Drive FIle Stream.
OK.
So if you remember
the four points
that we started this
presentation talking about,
we need a sharing,
organizational solution
that works for your users--
lines up with the expectations
that they have
coming from on-prem.
We need to deal with
your issues, the admin.
We have to solve migration.
And we have to make sure that
we don't break your business
processes after you migrate.
We've covered all of those.
Four launches.
Today, Team Drives.
DLP came in January.
Vault comes today.
The migration acquisition
with AppBridge and Drive File
Stream today.
If there's one
thing you take away
from this presentation,
what I want you to take away
is the Drive team, in
particular, in G Suite overall,
are heavily invested
in the needs of IT
leaders who are very cognizant
of the challenges you
face when trying to migrate
on to a solution like that.
And we are addressing
these problems.
If you remember that
left-right chart
that I had up at the beginning--
the revolutionary innovations
that come with the
chaos and the buildings
that have fallen down
or predictability.
Same old, same old--
not really helping
your business innovate.
We don't want you
to have to choose.
You should be able
to get both of these.
Google and Drive, we've always
invested heavily on the left.
We're known for that.
You know us for that.
We are now taking very seriously
the issues on the right.
This is not a
recent development.
It's been three
years in the making--
hundreds of engineering
years of effort
that have gone into this.
So that's where I should leave
it today, but one more thing.
The one more thing is
innovation, like I said,
is in our DNA.
And while we are
investing heavily
in the right-hand side of
that chart, we're Google,
we're Drive.
That is not all
that we're doing.
And I want to give
you a preview of where
Drive is going in the future.
It's really exciting.
It's what I personally find very
compelling about this project.
If you remember Prabhakar
Raghavan's keynote speech
this morning, he
announced that we
have 800 million monthly
active users of Drive.
That's not 800 million
people who have ever
signed up for an account.
We have 800 million people
who use it every month.
Those 800 million
people have stored
trillions of files in Drive.
And what gets me motivated
to work on this effort
is to think about what those
trillions of files represent.
They're not just documents that
have been stored somewhere.
What those files are, really in
the context of an enterprise,
they're the
enterprise's knowledge.
If I take the example of Google,
we're heavy duty users of this,
obviously.
It's every requirements
document that's ever
been written at the company.
It's every strategic analysis.
It's every business plan.
It's every post-mortem
for an outage.
All of these things
are stored in Drive.
And all of those things,
for an equivalent company
who might be on-prem, they're
all stored in their filers.
But is that filer or is that
enterprise content management
system doing anything to deliver
that content to the right users
at the right time
to help them be
more productive in their job?
No.
When was the last time
your H: popped up and said,
here's the thing you
need to know right now.
It's never happened.
And that's what I find really
compelling about this project.
So Drive's mission going
forward is to deliver knowledge,
to extract that knowledge
that's stored in the system,
and deliver it to the right
people within the organization
at the right time, in
particular, knowledge
workers who need
access to this content.
Now this might sound familiar.
If you've been around the
block a couple of times,
you probably remember--
it was 15 years ago--
all the enterprise
knowledge management systems
that were hot at the time.
And then over the
next 10 years it
became enterprise content
management systems.
One term gave way to
the other as people
started to realize these
solutions weren't delivering
on their promise.
The problem with enterprise
content management
today is that everything
in there is stale.
I've never heard anyone
say, my ECM system--
I find everything
I'm looking for.
First time, every time.
It's exactly what I
need to get my job done.
And the reason the
content there is
stale is that they require
people to go in and manually
add metadata tags.
This was a requirements
document and this
was on a project about
lighter-than-air flight
or whatever it was.
People don't do that.
It's like flossing.
Your dentist tells you
should floss every day.
You probably don't.
That's exactly how enterprise
content management systems are.
And, as Google, we have the
ability to solve that problem.
Today, we're announcing
Quick Access for Team Drives.
This is, really, a
revolution in Google Drive.
It might look very simple
and the user interface
is deceptively simple
on the surface.
It's four to 10 documents
that you probably
want to look at right now
in a sliding carousel,
but that's just the
tip of the iceberg.
What you don't realize, looking
at this very simple user
interface, is the
massive amount of machine
learning under the hood
that's powering this.
And what it's doing is it's
looking across your team.
What document has your
boss just commented on?
What are the trending
topics in your organization?
What meetings do you have
coming up later today?
And given all of
that information,
the machine learning model
processes what do you really
need to know right now?
No tagging required.
And it serves up that knowledge
to you at the right time
without anyone in
your organization
having to manually tag anything.
If you think about 800
million users and trillions
of documents stored in
Drive, this is the only way
to solve that problem.
There's no way individuals
could go in and tag and curate
that amount of data.
We really need the Google
machine learning capabilities
that you've heard so much
about at this conference.
We run custom silicon for
optimizing our machine
learning models, for example.
We're years ahead of
competitors there.
That's what's powering this.
And you can imagine where
this goes from here.
Not just delivering the document
you need at the right time,
but extracting the factual
content from those documents
and delivering it
to you, helping you
identify the experts
within your organization.
So if you're thinking about
migrating onto Drive, what
you need to know is you're going
to take all that content out
of your legacy content
management system.
You're going to put
it up into Drive
and that content will, over time
and continually, get unlocked
and the value is going
to get delivered to you.
Couple hard stats.
So Quick Access has been in
production for a set of users
now for a period of time.
It's one of the most impactful
projects of this sort
that I've ever seen at Google.
It's 52% faster than users
having to go and find
their content manually.
We can measure this empirically
in a controlled way.
It is already being
used to open 40%
of all the content in Drive.
For the users who
are using this,
almost half the
time Quick Access
delivers them right
what they need
and they don't have
to go find this.
This is not something
that's only getting
used out in the margins.
It's really, now, the
fundamental way people
find content in Drive.
And for the set of users who
have been using Quick Access so
far, every day it saves them
5 and 1/2 weeks of busy work,
digging around
looking for content.
So that's what you can
expect from us in the future.
That's why I'm really
excited to work on this.
And that all builds on this
enterprise-grade foundation
you just heard us
spend so much time on.
We know that you
wouldn't get access
to these kind of
capabilities, wouldn't
be able to access
them, without having
that enterprise-grade
foundation under the hood.
So three to-do's for the end
of the presentation here.
If you're a G Suite
customer, consider
rolling out Team Drives
to your organization.
It's under your control
when you roll it out.
There's a link there you
can follow with information.
Two, please sign up,
if you're interested,
in the Drive File Stream
Early Adopter Program.
That's if you're a
G Suite customer.
If you're not G Suite
customer, please consider us
for your next RFP.
We really think
we've done the work
to make Drive enterprise-grade.
It's ready for you.
We think it belongs
in your next RFP
and we will happily
provide you any data
that you need and spend quality
time with you in that process.
All right.
Thanks everyone for spending
the hour, really appreciate it.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]